a Cinderella story where that guy plays
the Prince for the sake of keeping the
Cinderella story kid-friendly I really
hope they cut the movie off before the
wedding to say guys still remember
[Music]
Cinderella so Cinderella is a
live-action telling of the story of
Cinderella brought to us by director
Kenneth Branagh he gave his jack ryan
shadow recruit the first Thor movie that
did pretty accomplished he's a sir now
so it's Sir Kenneth Bryan and the story
in this movie Cinderella is exactly what
you remember the story of Cinderella
being it's not like Snow White in the
Huntsman it's not like Maleficent it's
not like it's this new edgy dark take on
the story that you knew for the young
audience of 2015 who are eagerly
awaiting their copy of Mortal Kombat X
next month on it's like this story is
Cinderella it's exactly a you remember
it but it's live-action you don't know
the story of Cinderella now can
alignment be thoroughly its surprised if
not impressed
I don't know how that one skipped right
by the new stuff they do in this movies
it shows more about Cinderella's dad you
know gives you more backstory on the
stepmother in that the first half an
hour in this movie did kind of drag on
but it's building character so I get it
you do need gay it's a live action movie
it's funny how that works you have the
animation oh yeah we can just jump right
into Cinderella and you get it you're a
kid you don't care as long as your mom
is still putting fruit snacks in your
lunchbox for school you're good but it's
live action so they gotta go in a little
more detail Oh Kate Blanchet played the
role the stepmother really well she was
her and her stepdaughters were a little
cartoony at times I'm not the only thing
in this movie some of the humor glad it
was in it but it was awkwardly out of
place sometimes kids aren't gonna care
about that they're gonna giggle laugh
have a good time but the parents are
gonna be like it's a little out of place
and awkward is strange I do like the
girl who played Cinderella and she did
work well in the dynamic the movie does
a good job at showing that she's just
the best person ever and she's in the
worst situation ever living with the
worst people ever short of Walder Frey
that guy can attest to that but
ultimately this movie is pretty by the
numbers it's an accurate representation
of the Disney cartoon that everyone grew
up with and now it's live-action and it
is what it is and that there are not
many secrets in this movie there are a
couple of different twists they do on
situational circumstances it's movie
compared to the animation but all in all
it's exactly what you know and kids are
gonna have a good time with this movie
and that's what the movies for so in
that making this review as quick as
possible I like the girl who played
Ella I liked cate blanchett as the
stepmother i thought she was a little
cartoony at times not as much as her
stepdaughters but she was still good in
it and there are a few scenes in this
movie that really hits you're like oh my
gosh Cinderella I feel bad for you and
the movie should do that as long as it
can give you the feels it has it has its
hooks in you it's a traditional Disney
movie experience and I like seeing that
it really took me back and I was like oh
they can still do that so I will say
Cinderella is a pretty good time no
alcohol required or so Cinderella have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]